and he goes up against brandon woodruff
who's looking for his first win since
june 29th tim
he has been exceptional though along the
way i mean you look at he's in his 22nd
start
i mean his innings are there 131 innings
you this is the most innings he's thrown
since the minor leagues back in 2016.
so what we're seeing right now is just
an idea of what he looks like
into a deep major league season and for
the most part it's been outstanding to
watch
lamont wade junior on base twice
yesterday against corbin burns
2-2 pitch struck him out looking at 98
good
start for brandon chris bryant getting
his usual
greeting from brewer fans here at
american family field of former cub
swinging a jam job ground ball
hit to short escobar cuts it up throws
on a tough hop
and teles handled it nicely at first
base
very good play and thank you says
eduardo escobar
playing at third base tonight he ranged
far off the bag to make the pick up on
that one
williams had a shot at it and may have
thrown him out too but i think
escobar had the best shot kane chopper
towards the middle
crawford diving stab safe at second
should be an infield single for lorenzo
kane it would have been an unbelievable
play and i believe they would have had
tyrone tanner at second
it was a diving stab and crawford
flipped it to le stella covering its
second base and he dropped it
two away and brandon woodruff with an
opportunity to drive in a run
on the ground and a fair ball belt's got
it and he'll take it to the bag himself
for out number three man aboard now for
williams
that's a fair ball down the left field
line extra bases
let's see colton long run he's going to
be sent around
third he's going to try and score and
will with ease
one nothing brewers on the double by
adamus
adonis and the brewers strike first for
willia domes he drives in number 59 on
the season
first pitch to him and it's a drive out
to left back on it is dickerson at the
track he's got room he makes the catch
and the inning is over tellez almost
added another chapter
to the folklore brandon woodruff has
been sparkling so far five strikeouts
and there's one away now for brandon
belts one two
bell hits that one out toward right
center field kane
all the way back and it is gone brandon
belt
second game in a row and that ties it up
one to one
back-to-back games against two tough
pitchers and one swing in the back we
got a tie ball game
i'll tell you what not that he needs it
that's a resume builder you homer
against burns and woodruff
like a change-up to me and he went down
and got it he's got to deal with mikey
stremski struck him out to end the
second inning woodruff trying to
limit the giants and loaded for san
francisco
struck him out big old hook from brandon
woodruff
and he strikes out yastrimsky looking
for a big second out in the inning
now dickerson with two outs base is
still loaded 1-1 pitch
popped him up willie adamus and colton
long converging on the right side adamus
says i got it
and he does and the inning is over
brandon woodruff gets
tough 1-0 pitch fly ball
shallow right this is going to be
trouble if it's fair racing in
is wait he won't get there it's a fair
ball it'll roll all the way into the
corner
taylor off to the races he's around
second and he dives into third
safely with the triple mom wade junior
was playing tyrone
taylor way in the gap in right center
had
so far to go to try and make that catch
now here's lorenzo with the infield
drawn in
on one fly ball center field
well deep enough yastremski makes the
catch
tagging and scoring his taylor
two-to-one brewers
sac fly off the battle lorenzo kane he
drives in his 16th of the year
it's to lamont wade jr that's hit hard
to right
back garcia still back wanting track
just caught it
fires back into second base not in time
a great catch made by abby garcia saving
an extra base hit
but probably got a little too much on it
looked like it was almost
slicing downward great play by garcia
now belt solo home run his last time up
on a change up
here it is hey struck him out
swinging down lowing in with a nasty
slider gets the strikeout
and the giants are finished last time up
drew a
walk in a big spot giants down by run
sixth inning
that one is lined into left field chris
bryant's got himself a hit
taylor scoops it up so crawford's gonna
have to stay
at second but chris bryant having
another nice game for the giants some
good defense on base for the second time
and with two down alec dickerson is
going to be the batter
one more out to get for woodruff to get
through six
here comes what a struck him out
swinging
he threw him a breaking ball down and in
the dirt
manny pina gobbled it up and the inning
is over
it's another strikeout so here's wade
kicks and the pitch popped him up
shallow left racing is taylor this is
going to take a lot of ground to cover
and he makes a sliding catch in foul
territory
to indiana tyrone taylor had to cover a
ton of real estate he's right on the
foul line as he went into a slide
and slid into foul as he made the catch
it would have been a fair ball
trying to pick up his first big league
save here in the ninth
gets that one high down the right field
line and deep
garcia back at the wall and he's missed
it
he didn't catch it bryant is on his way
to the plate
la stella is on his way to third and the
giants have miraculously tied this game
at two
flores to left taylor catches
inning over brandon bell has been
intentionally walked
to load the bases for buster posey here
comes
buster on the ground and it gets through
into center field
estrada scores wade right behind him
he scores it's 4-2 crawford coming up
we'll see what the brewers
want to do here 2-0 down the left-field
line
and that should be plenty deep enough
taylor makes a catch tagging from third
belt even not moving real fast belt
scores
five to two giants maria's to
is the automatic runner out there at
second down by three
ureas straight away center back
loading track it's gone a two-round
blast
for luisa just like that the brewers are
within one
rbi double back in the third for him
one-two pitch high drive deep center
slater's back at the track bye-bye
baseball
we are tied milwaukee will bring its
infield in
is now wade vance with slater at third
wade basic right field lamont wade comes
through
slater scores giants back ahead six to
five and bell would like to make the
brewers pay he is a one for four a home
run back in the fourth inning
three two that one is hit deep to right
field garcia watches it it's gone
granite belt his second home run of the
night
and the giants have another three run
extra inning lead it's eight to five
now it's chris bryant ryan swings and he
drives this one toward right center
field
this ball has some carry to it it's off
the wall posey
will score bryant on his way to second
he goes in with a slide
it's nine to five 0-2 pitch to lorenzo
kane
little flare shallow right gonna fall
brewers get a run it's 9-6 you get one
more base runner and that sends the
tying run of the plate again
popped up and that should do it
crawford underneath it and the giants
have another
amazing win